SAAD ALI: Hello, everyone.
We're here at KubeCon
Barcelona with Matt Moore.
Matt is one of the
co-founders of Knative,
as well as GCR, the
Google Container Registry.
Matt, let's talk about
GCR in the early days.
Where did it start?
MATT MOORE: So
around the same time
that Kubernetes was
starting up and Google
was looking at Docker, which
was popularizing containers,
it became pretty clear that
if we launched a container
service, we were going to
need a way for our customers
to have really good
integrated experience
to ship their container
images to that service, right?
And so a few of us started to
motivate and build that team.
And we were tracking
the project 7.
And then Kubernetes
worked very closely,
because we believed it was
going to be a big deal.
It's kind of hard to imagine it
would become this big a deal.
But yeah, like, we were in
on the kool-aid pretty early.
And yeah, it's been amazing
to see GCR and Kubernetes,
well beyond that, just
become incredibly successful.
SAAD ALI: Yeah, it is amazing.
And now you're involved
with a new project, Knative.
Can you tell us a little
bit more about that?
MATT MOORE: Sure.
So GCR sort of led me to
doing a whole bunch of stuff
with container tools.
And I've been working
with [INAUDIBLE]
and our boss, Tomas, for many
years in the container space.
And a couple years ago--
a year and a half to
two years ago now--
we had this sprint,
where we wanted
to look at what it would
be like to build serverless
on Kubernetes.
And there was some
early prototyping,
and then a sprint that
ultimately led to us deciding,
yeah, we're going to do this.
We're going to do this thing.
And that ultimately
became Knative.
SAAD ALI: Cool.
So what are some of
the biggest challenges
that Knative deals with?
MATT MOORE: So there are
the three main areas--
build, serving, and venting.
I think there are
a lot of things
that were really hard problems
a couple of years ago.
I think in the build
space, some of the stuff
that's happened in the
build working group--
on-cluster builds seem
much more tractable
now than they did a year ago.
And serving, scaling, as rapidly
as a lot of people expect from
serverless-- cold starts,
things like that--
it's still a really
hard problem,
and it's going to be
one of those things
that zero millisecond
startups aren't going to be
fast enough for some people.
So it's going to be
one of these things
that we're going to have
to invest in forever, just
like Kubernetes
and scale, right?
And then eventing,
right, like there's going
to be an endless source of--
sources, where people
are going to want
to be like, when that happens,
I want to do something.
So there are these
interesting and huge problems.
And then even just
organizationally,
how are we going to manage
the complexity of all
of these things over time?
So a lot of
interesting challenges.
SAAD ALI: Cool.
So what is the current status
of the Knative project, and what
are the features that
you're excited about?
MATT MOORE: So we just cut
0.6, I think, last Tuesday.
It is my favorite
release so far.
We launched the beginnings
of our beta API there.
And we hope that that will
be a near-final API shape
that we can take through to V1.
And a bunch of other
really cool features
launched, like auto-TLS
and some other things that
allow you to get a really good
experience all the way through
to TLS-terminated
URL, with little
to no work on the
developer side,
once an operator has sort
of set things up for you.
Looking at that core
of functionality
that we've been really
iterating on so far,
we want to get that to GA.
And then we can start
to look at iterating
on improving some of the stuff
around scale, performance,
as well as starting to get into
the rhythm of feature track
releases for new stuff.
There's always new stuff.
SAAD ALI: Now you have a
managed version by Google
called Cloud Run of Knative.
Why a managed solution?
MATT MOORE: So as with
Kubernetes and Istio,
getting things set up
just right isn't always
the easiest thing in the world.
And I think [? Kelsey ?]
has a great--
Kubernetes the hard way, right?
Thankfully, it's not that
hard, because Kubernetes has
done a lot to get that set up.
But I mentioned DNS and TLS.
Getting that set up just right
on the cluster is pretty hard.
And we want the managed
service to make that,
the out-of-the-box
experience, really easy,
so that you can focus on the
things that you actually want
to focus on, and not
the boring stuff.
We want to solve the
boring stuff for you.
SAAD ALI: So let folks
focus on the problems
that they care about,
rather than infrastructure.
That's awesome.
So last question.
We're here at KubeCon.
This is the biggest
KubeCon so far.
What are you excited
about seeing this week?
MATT MOORE: I think the most
surreal thing has been--
you know, you walk
around, and when
you hear people talking
about this project
that you've helped start and
they don't realize you're
there, that's pretty cool.
And seeing product
announcements,
like the [? Rancher ?]
announcement
I think yesterday
or today, where
they're launching things based
on Knative that you didn't even
know about.
And it's great.
It's really cool to
see those things.
But honestly, one of my
favorite things to do here
is to talk to all of the vendors
that are here at the booths,
and see what they're doing,
and find ways to collaborate
and help build the community.
That's definitely one of
my favorite things to do.
And connect with
contributors who
I feel like I know
really, really well
but am meeting for the
first time in person.
There's a few of them that I've
just met for the first time
this week.
And yeah, they're great people.
And I love working with them.
SAAD ALI: Thank you
so much for your time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]